[MUSICAL SOUND EFFECT]
SPEAKER 1: All right,
let's get started.
So today we're really excited
to welcome Shalane Flanagan
and Elyse Kopecky.
From being college
roommates at Chapel Hill,
they both went on to some
very fascinating careers.
Shalane has set a lot
of records for running.
She has run in four
Olympic Games now,
winning the bronze medal in one.
And just a few weeks
ago, she won sixth,
leading the American team.
She holds a record for the
3,000-meter and 5,000-meter
indoors and for 10K
and 15K road races.
It's fascinating
to me, personally,
how long she's been able
to stay on top of her game,
since so many athletes peak
or only do a single Olympics.
Elyse works for Nike Running
doing digital marketing
after she graduated, and
then did a career change
and went to culinary
school in New York City.
So when we look
at this cookbook,
we know that the authors have
serious chops, both in knowing
running and in knowing cooking.
So it's no wonder it made "The
New York Times'" best seller
list.
Please welcome
Shalane and Elyse.
[APPLAUSE]
ELYSE KOPECKY: Thank
you so much, Pete,
for having us here at Google.
It's such an honor to be here.
For me, I always admired
Google as a company.
I worked in digital marketing
at Nike for almost 10 years.
And if I hadn't been
working at Nike,
I probably would have wanted
to come work at Google.
So it's awesome to be here and
see what an amazing campus you
guys have.
And today, we've been
traveling all over
as part of our book tour.
We've had a chance to go to
some awesome running cities
and speak to runners and
athletes of all levels.
And for us, this is
an opportunity for us
to spread such an important
message to athletes.
And what we're teaching people
is there is more to healthy
eating than just kale juice.
Health food is a juicy burger.
We want to teach people
that healthy food doesn't
have to be bland and boring.
It can be really nourishing
and really flavorful,
and keep you satisfied so you're
not reaching for junk food.
So I'm going to dive into that.
But first, I know
you guys probably
want to hear some stories
from Shalane, since she's just
returned from an
incredible race in Rio.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
So about a couple weeks ago, I
ran a little race down in Rio.
And it was an
incredible experience.
It was my fourth, but I
never take it for granted,
getting to wear USA
across my chest.
There's so much pride
and honor behind that.
And the race itself--
I had high expectations
hoping to land on the podium
and wear a nice, little necklace
around my neck after the
race, but that didn't happen.
I placed sixth.
But we had the highest finish
for an American team ever.
We won sixth, seventh,
and ninth, which was huge.
We have definitely
a tough challenge,
where the East Africans seem
to dominate the distances,
so it was quite an
accomplishment for us.
But I did have to
overcome a lot of fear,
actually, for this last race.
My Olympic trials to qualify
for the marathon was in LA.
And if any of you have
run in the heat before,
the heat can be pretty
taxing and arduous.
And so I'd never
run a heat marathon,
except for in LA at
the Olympic trials.
And that's, obviously,
kind of a tough race
because you're trying
to make the Olympic team
and you have to
finish top three.
And I ended up having
a really hard race.
And the final three
miles, I barely finished,
but I hung on for third.
And so I created a lot of fear.
First time I'd ever had to
receive an IV after the race.
And it kind of scarred me, that
experience running in such a
deprived dehydration state.
And you think at this level,
I would know everything,
but clearly I don't.
So I had a lot of
fear going into Rio.
Because again, it was going
to be a hot and humid race.
So I had to overcome a lot
of fear going into that.
I reached out to a lot of
resources to overcome that fear
and got a hydration plan.
I relied on my best friend
to help me come up with that.
And then, a lot of research.
I went to Olympic
Training Center
and did a hydration analysis.
And apparently, they classify
me as an aggressive sweater.
So I had to probably
drink three times more
than the rest of the
athletes out there,
but I was able to do that and
had a successful marathon.
But beyond that,
I talk about fear.
Elyse and I completely made
career changes a little bit
and collaborated on
this beautiful cookbook.
And three years ago,
that idea started just
at my kitchen table while we
were eating a delicious meal.
And Elyse had made
some career changes,
and I had made the goal to
make a fourth Olympic team.
And we came up,
basically over this meal,
the idea of writing a cookbook.
And sharing the
knowledge that she gained
and how I felt kind of
deprived and just a burden
with my own diet as an athlete.
And I wanted to make sure
that I was fueling properly.
So that's how it began.
And Elyse will share a
little bit more of the story.
ELYSE KOPECKY: Great.
So thanks.
So it's been such an honor
for me to write this cookbook.
We've known each
other for 16 years,
so to get to write a cookbook
together has been a lot of fun.
We were college
roommates and teammates,
and then we both had
the chance to move west
after graduating from UNC.
And then, working for Nike
in different capacities.
I worked in a cubicle while
Shalane was down below
on the fields running laps.
And I always would
look out my window
and wish I was down
there on the field, too.
And anyways, the
cookbook came to be.
We hadn't seen each
other in a couple years.
And I had the chance
during my career
in marketing to work abroad.
I worked in Geneva, Switzerland,
for a not-to-be-named video
game company.
And during that time,
I got really inspired
by the food culture
in Switzerland.
My diet changed drastically
when we moved over there from--
and I had suffered in college.
I suffered from a
lot of injuries.
And I thought I
was healthy eater.
And what I had been
eating in college
that led to stress
fractures and led
to me suffering from
athletic amenorrhea,
it went away as soon as
I moved to Switzerland
and changed my diet.
My diet changed from eating
white meat chicken breast
to whole roasted chicken.
And from veggie burgers
to grass-fed ground beef.
And from processed, fake
butter spreads to real butter.
And all these
decadent foods that we
had learned to label in
our country as unhealthy
actually made me healthier,
and happier, and stronger
than ever before.
And so I had this
realization that I
had been depriving myself
of these amazing foods that
not only tasted great, but were
also helping my body absorb
vitamins and nutrients
so much better than what
I had been eating running
at a high level in college.
And I decided that I wanted
to be able to inspire
other athletes of all levels.
And so we moved
back to the US and I
went to study culinary nutrition
at a top school in New York
City.
And after that, wasn't really
sure what I was going to do
and how I would get my
message out to athletes.
But we had the
chance to have dinner
together and be reunited.
We hadn't seen each other.
So that night, we were
talking and sharing stories
from college and catching
up on good times.
But soon our conversation
got more serious
and we talked about how
many athletes we had seen
suffer at every level, from
our own teammates in college
to a lot of young
female athletes
suffering due to eating
mostly processed foods diets,
and counting
calories, and feeling
like they had to follow a
prescription way of eating.
And seeing food just as
fuel instead of seeing it
as indulgent nourishment.
And so that night I said to
Shalane-- Shalane told me
how she always felt while she
was marathon training, drained
and hangry.
And she just felt
depleted all the time.
And I told her that night,
maybe you just need more butter
in your life, too.
So we quickly started
revamping her diet.
And we thought, maybe we should
write a cookbook together
some day so we can
get this message out
to thousands of runners across
the country and athletes.
And I never actually thought
we would get our courage up
to write the book,
but a whole year
went by with a lot of text
messages back and forth,
and more dinners together.
And finally-- it
took my daughter
being born for me to realize,
like this is what I need to do.
And I quit all my other projects
to write our book proposal
full time and just went for it.
And I tried to channel Shalane's
energy and competitive edge
as much as possible.
And I poured everything
into our book proposal.
We sent it out not knowing
if anyone would ever
want to publish our book.
We said, well, if nobody
wants to publish it,
we'll publish it ourselves.
So we sent it out to publishers
and we ended up with eight bids
for our book.
So we got to pick
our first choice
publisher, which was Rodale.
And they've done an amazing job
of making the beautiful book
that we had envisioned.
And sticking to our nutrition
philosophy, which is-- we
came to call it
indulgent nourishment.
And indulgent
nourishment, we wanted
to prove to people that
healthy food can be cool.
It doesn't have to be bland.
And you can eat
these amazing foods
and use local,
seasonal ingredients,
and top it with
olive oil and olive
oil-based dressing
or buttery sauce.
And by eating this way,
eating these real foods
and fueling yourself, you
don't have the cravings
anymore for the junk, and the
bars, and the packaged foods.
So we are proud to have the
first cookbook for runners
that doesn't have calorie
counts or nutrition facts.
And instead, we're
teaching people
to get back in
tune with listening
to their body's needs.
And we've been beyond excited
by the amount of media.
The media has been really
excited about our book.
It's appeared in "Runner's
World" and "Women's Running"
magazine and "Outside"
magazine and "Food & Wine."
And we were just a couple
weeks ago in New York City,
to be on "Good Morning America."
And best of all, like we
had this really high goal
that people told us we
would never achieve,
which was to make the "New
York Times Bestseller" list.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: We didn't
even know how that happened,
or [INAUDIBLE].
We're like, that's
the best, right?
We're going to
shoot for the best.
ELYSE KOPECKY: Yeah.
So Shalane's competitive, and
I channel her competitiveness.
SHALANE FLANAGAN:
Whatever it is that we do.
ELYSE KOPECKY: So we really
poured our heart and soul
into this book.
And we want not only to inspire
people to get into the kitchen,
but to inspire people
to seek out the best
ingredients for their body.
To buy local, seasonal food.
It's not only better for the
planet and better for you.
It just is more
nutrient-dense, so it
will leave you feeling
satisfied and more energized,
and not reaching for
a sugar fix and not
reaching for a coffee fix all
day, which I've noticed you
guys have opportunities
for coffee fixes.
Not that coffee's bad.
And as part of that, we tried
to show people and prove
that dieting doesn't work.
A lot of people in our
country are yo-yo dieting.
And every year, it's a
different kind of diet.
Whether that's a paleo
diet, or a low-fat diet,
or juicing, or any of
these extreme diets.
And the science is there now
and we go into it in the book,
but diets just-- they're no fun.
They cause your body to
have metabolism swings.
And in the end, a lot of
people try these diets
and they don't work.
And they end up gaining weight.
And instead when you
begin to eat real food
and take the time to get
in the kitchen and cook,
you'll feel so much
better than ever before.
And one of the things
we tell that's kind
of our most important message
is the single greatest thing
you can do as an athlete
to improve your performance
and your health and happiness
is to learn to cook.
And Pete was just
showing us how you guys
have a kitchen here where
you can learn to cook,
which is amazing.
So I highly recommend
that you take advantage
of the cooking classes here.
People often tell us, I
don't have time to cook.
I have a full-time job and
I'm training and I have kids.
And if Shalane can
go in the kitchen
and cook after a 28-mile
training run at high altitude,
and make homemade
sauce and homemade
meatballs and a
hearty grain salad,
then I think the
rest of us can too.
A lot of people think, well,
she must have a private chef
cooking all of her meals.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: I wish.
I'm going to hire you.
ELYSE KOPECKY: In fact, she's
not only cooking for herself,
but often going
to training camps
and cooking for all
of her teammates, too.
So it's pretty
impressive to see that.
And I'll let her talk about
some of her favorite recipes
in the book here in a second.
But the other thing I wanted
to share about the good fats.
So all of our recipes
are full of flavor.
And the reason
they're so flavorful
is because they're so rich
in good, healthy fats.
And there's been kind of
ingrained in our culture
over the years, since when we
were in high school and college
that fat is bad for you.
And fat causes heart conditions.
And fat causes weight gain.
When in fact, the
opposite is true.
Fat prevents weight gain.
Fat helps regulate
your metabolism.
It helps you feel energized.
It's a great source of energy.
Runners get so focused on
protein, protein, protein,
and carbo loading.
And really, fat is a
great source of energy.
It helps when you're eating a
salad or veggies, or something
hearty and healthy and
you put fat on top of it,
it helps your body absorb all
the vitamins and nutrients
better.
Many vitamins are fat-soluble,
so you can't get the most out
of the foods you're
eating without having
the fat in your diet.
And especially for
Google employees,
fat is so important
for brain health.
So it keeps you smarter.
It prevents depression.
So anyone who
works here probably
had a mom that was cooking
good meals with healthy fats
as a kid because that's
how you guys got here.
It was good for
your brain health.
I have a toddler
who's two years old,
and she eats this
incredible way of eating.
I know it's really good
for her brain development.
So especially for kids, where
their brains are developing,
they need the good
fats in their diet.
We talk about butter
because we love butter.
But it's not just butter.
You have a range of fats.
You have coconut
oil, and olive oil,
and even fat from really
good quality meat sources.
So grass-fed ground
beef and eggs.
And for us, we prefer dark meat
chicken over white meat chicken
because it's got more of the
good, nourishing fats in there.
And also, more
vitamins and minerals.
So there's lots of sources
of great, healthy fats.
The ones you want to
avoid are the cheap oils
that are in packaged foods.
And there is a lot of
packaged foods out there.
When I say packaged
foods, people
think of chips and cookies,
but there's so much more.
It's also the dressings, and the
sauces, and all the quick fixes
that we have in
our grocery store
to get dinner on
the table faster.
But in our book,
we teach people how
to make dressings from
scratch, and sauces, and pesto,
and hummus.
And when you're making
these foods from scratch,
you're able to use
really good oils.
Whereas, if you're buying hummus
in the grocery store, which
sounds like healthy
food, it's often
made with cheap oils
and preservatives, which
aren't great for your body.
So we really want to inspire
people to get in the kitchen,
and put on an apron, and
have fun with cooking.
Make it an activity you
do on Sunday afternoon
to prepare meals for
the week and to have
stuff prepared in advance.
So I'm going to let Shalane
share-- talk about some
of her favorite recipes and how
these foods have helped her.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: I'll
share the one favorite
that's gained celebrity status.
If we were to
measure our celebrity
status through Instagram at
least, one measuring tool.
So these are our
superhero muffins.
And as you can see,
they look delicious.
You can make them with
chocolate chips or not.
I support the chocolate chips.
So these are great.
Really satiating, because they
have some good butter in it.
And they also are made
with almond flour,
which is a little bit different
than your traditional flour.
So they're very satiating.
They stick in my stomach.
And I feel like I don't
get hungry for hours
later, which is great.
Because I don't want to
be running around hangry,
as Elyse describes it.
So I'll have these
for breakfast.
I will have them as a snack.
I'll have them for dessert.
They're a staple.
And people are cooking
these up like crazy.
They're definitely different
because we're tricking people.
They taste awesome, but they've
got zucchini and carrots in it,
too.
These are what we classify
as a long Sunday run.
"These muffins were designed
for superheroes like you.
They're packed full of veggies
and sweetened with maple syrup
instead of refined sugar.
In addition, almond meal
and whole grain oats
replace nutrient-stripped
white flour.
These are my go-to
muffins, nourishing
and sweetly satisfying for an
easy grab and run breakfast.
And do not fear the butter.
Fueling up with healthy fats is
a great way to start your day.
Fat helps transport
important vitamins
throughout your
hard-working body.
Will help keep you
satisfied longer."
So yeah, I recommend--
these are a huge hit
for kids, for
husbands/wives, for parties.
They're amazing.
ELYSE KOPECKY: Do you
want to talk about some
of the other foods that
you loved training for Rio?
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
Let's see.
So I pretty much
primarily-- a lot of people
say, once you
create this cookbook
and you've already tested all
these recipes numerous times,
have eaten all of them, it
feels like 100 times each.
But I generally don't
stray from the cookbook.
I feel like I can
rely on this because I
know every ingredient is going
to have-- is power-packed.
Everything I'm putting
in my body has a purpose.
And I like knowing that.
And I can control that.
I always say in
athletics, you control
what you can control because
there's a lot of variables
you can't control.
So I try to control what
I'm putting in for fuel.
I'd say another favorite food
is our high-altitude bison
meatballs.
These are also a huge hit.
I had 10 teammates go to the
Olympics this summer in Rio,
and I mad these up probably
once a week for them.
And bison, we eat
quite a bit of bison
because it's really
rich in iron,
which is really important
for endurance athletes.
Because for an
endurance athlete,
especially if I train
at high altitude,
I need the red blood
cell production.
And that gives me energy.
It transports the
oxygen. So there's
thought and stories behind
each one of these recipes.
And on top of being healthy
for me, they're delicious.
I crave them.
So I think in the
past, I used to just
eat super-bland and boring.
And I wasn't excited
to eat my food.
And I just felt like this
burden, like I was describing.
And counting calories.
And worrying about getting
to this race weight,
which is optimal
for performance.
And I used to stress about it.
And now I feel like I can
indulge in these great foods
and not have to worry
about my race weight.
I find it comes naturally
now without all the stress
of counting.
I think it was actually
counterproductive.
So I'm just hoping that
these recipes can really
enhance whatever goals
you have, athletically
or just health-wise.
ELYSE KOPECKY: A lot
of people ask us--
we're going to have
some time for questions,
but I'll go ahead and
ask the question that I
know we're going to get asked.
Everyone asks us at every
stop, every city, well,
I don't run 100 miles a week.
Can I eat these foods?
And really, this is--
SHALANE FLANAGAN: So I run 120.
ELYSE KOPECKY: Sorry.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: A lot
of people are like, whoa.
Well, I don't run that much.
So do these really apply to me?
Can I really eat that?
And the answer is yes.
ELYSE KOPECKY: This is
for anyone of any level.
Whether your marathon
is a 12-hour day
at Google, or chasing after
a toddler is your running.
My running is three
to five miles.
And often with a stroller
and not every day.
It really varies.
And when you eat this way,
this is good food for anyone.
When you eat this
way, you're just
so satisfied and so
energized that you're
going to want to get out
there and do these adventures
on the one hand.
And then, just real food
doesn't cause weight gain.
It's all the sugars
and processed foods.
So if you really
make a commitment
to sourcing good
ingredients and getting
in your kitchen and
cooking, then, yes, you
can eat this way, too.
So yeah, if anyone
has questions,
we have time for answering.
SPEAKER 1: So we have a mic set
up right here for questions.
Please form a line and
ask your questions.
AUDIENCE: I actually
have a couple questions.
The most important
question for me
is, how do you source the--
what do you call it, good food?
Like for example, beef.
So I have tried
different kinds of beef
before and there is
only one source of beef
I had that was really good.
But that's from Hawaii, and
it's really hard to get to.
ELYSE KOPECKY: You
guys are really
blessed with access in Seattle
to incredible ingredients.
So I would really
highly recommend
getting to know your farmers
at your local farmers' market.
And buying direct
from a farmer is
going to give you the
best source of beef.
When you go to
the grocery store,
you have the options of organic.
Some higher-end grocery stores,
like natural food grocery
stores, will also have
a grass-fed option.
So I always choose
the grass-fed option.
Organic labeling is
a bit misleading,
because it's gotten to be so
mainstream that now you have
mass-produced organic foods.
So any time that you can get
your food closer to the source.
And in Seattle, you
have amazing access
to local farmers' markets.
That's the best bet.
If you can, make a commitment
to go to a farmers' market
once a month.
But even if you don't have time
to go to the farmers' market,
a lot of farms will
deliver direct.
So even where I live
in Bend, Oregon,
there's a CSA, which is
a Community Supported
Agriculture or farm share.
And they will deliver.
I don't know if Google has
deliveries direct to here.
But in Bend, you can have
produce and meat delivered
direct to your office
or to your home, which
is an awesome opportunity.
And a lot of the food labels
are really misleading.
You see grass-fed and
cage-free and all of this.
But when you're buying
direct from the farmer,
you don't have to stress
when you're getting it
from small, local farms.
They're the ones
who are committed
to taking care of
their land because they
want to be able to pass their
farm down from generations.
We have a great source,
a farmer we love.
It's Pine Mountain
Ranch in Bend, Oregon,
just outside of where I live.
And they have a website,
Pine Mountain Ranch.
And you can order
amazing bison and yak
and have it delivered-- mailed
with ice packs and [INAUDIBLE].
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yak?
Ew.
ELYSE KOPECKY: My daughter
loves yak, my two-year-old.
AUDIENCE: Did you
say Pine Mountain?
ELYSE KOPECKY: Pine
Mountain Ranch.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Washington.
So they deliver to Google,
but they don't include meats.
They only have
vegetables and fruits.
[INAUDIBLE] good.
AUDIENCE: I don't want
to just keep on asking.
But I do have another question.
So you mentioned
dark meat chicken.
So what does that mean?
I have never heard--
ELYSE KOPECKY: Chicken thighs.
So when I buy chicken,
I buy a whole chicken.
And I get it from a
good, reputable farmer
or reputable grocery store.
Even like Whole Foods, you
can buy the whole chicken
and use every part of it.
And that's the best
way to eat meat,
because you get-- the dark
meat is the thigh and the leg.
But also, I use every
part of the chicken.
So we don't eat a lot of
meat, but we definitely
have meat every day.
We eat it as like a side.
So we have a lot of
vegetables, an then meat
is a smaller side dish.
When you use every
part of it, you
can make bone broth,
which is an incredibly
mineral-rich, nourishing
tonic, which is great
for fighting inflammation,
and for recovery,
and for preventing-- we're
getting into flu season.
So we have a recipe in
here for bone broth.
And then you can make a chicken
stew, which is full of chicken
and garlic and really good for
boosting your immune system.
AUDIENCE: I also have a
question about-- [INAUDIBLE].
So there's meat.
There's veggies, but we also
eat a lot of flour and rice.
How do you source
those kind of things?
Like from Costco or
from Whole Foods?
Where do you source them?
Because we need to use a lot
of them, like on regular basis.
ELYSE KOPECKY: My favorite
source for whole grains
is Bob's Red Mill.
And you can find it
at a lot of-- even
like a Safeway or
mainstream grocery store,
you can find Bob's Red Mill.
They're based in Oregon and they
have all kinds of whole grains.
Like you can get
farro and quinoa.
And you can get ground
flours, too, for baking.
We have a lot of wholesome
treats in our book,
and they're made with
whole-grain flours.
Rice.
I would say we like to stick
to short-grain brown rice.
Brown rice is more nutritious.
I like short-grain
just for the texture.
And you can find that
in the bulk section
at any health food store.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question about during
and post-workout nutrition.
I find that it's
really hard, obviously,
while you're running and
then immediately afterwards.
The last thing I want
to do after a long run
is stand in the kitchen for
20 minutes cooking something.
Do you pre-make food, or
how do you handle that?
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
Concerning while you're running.
Do you consume a
sports drink or gel?
AUDIENCE: I've been
using power bars.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Power bars.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Not super-happy
with it, but [INAUDIBLE].
SHALANE FLANAGAN: We
have some treats in here
that are great for while you're
running as well as post-run.
My favorite that
we have are banana
chews, which are
just natural bananas.
But they're cooked a
little bit [INAUDIBLE].
They're chewy.
You see a lot of
the sports gummies.
So it replaces the
synthetic, kind of gummies
and the simple sugars that
are not as great for you.
We also have what we call
giddy-up energy bars.
And they're made with dates, and
a variety of dried fruit, and--
ELYSE KOPECKY: Nuts.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Nuts in it.
So dates and nuts are a
great source to fuel you.
When I'm competing, I
just drink a sports drink.
But that's necessary.
There's time and
place where you're
drinking the sports drink.
Otherwise, I'm drinking
usually like a coconut water
most of the time, or
just simple water.
After a run, the last
thing you want to do
is get in the kitchen.
So sometimes, I'll try
to prepare a little bit
and cook maybe
half my meal prior.
But right after a run, I
usually have our beet smoothie.
It sounds weird.
It's delicious.
So that really just gets
something in immediately.
Because you have a little window
to refuel and it will make
you feel a lot better.
And if you refuel
right away, you're
going to be a little bit
more motivated to get
in the kitchen.
My go-to, though, once
I get in the kitchen,
are just some veggies
and scrambled eggs.
Really simple.
Yeah.
Elyse, do you have
anymore to add?
ELYSE KOPECKY: Yeah.
If you're not hungry
right after you
run because you're so thirsty,
a smoothie is a great solution.
And especially if you're
putting other ingredients
in there besides fruits and
veggies to balance out--
you don't want to just
have this big sugar rush.
So putting almond
butter in there
for the good fat and
whole-milk yogurt is amazing.
You need a good, organic
whole-milk yogurt.
Mixing that into your
smoothie is great.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question,
your views on carbs.
So on the one hand,
it's the fuel,
like we do carb loading
before a marathon.
And probably,
during the training.
And on the other hand, there are
a lot of views against carbs.
I read the book from
[INAUDIBLE] and the "Big
Book of Endurance."
That book have some extreme
views, but it does help a lot.
They also have the
quick recipes there.
He's totally
against using carbs.
And even against carb
loading before a marathon.
And he also recommends
things like grass-fed beef
from local farms.
So what's your view on carbs?
SHALANE FLANAGAN: If I were to
just ask all the women that I
compete against
men in the Olympics
who are running the
marathon, endurance athletes,
none of them would
not consume carbs.
They need carbs.
You need glycogen to
do an endurance event.
That being said, I would
not do he no carbs.
We're not really into
any trend at all.
We just think that what
you eat on a daily basis
and weekly basis,
and in your training,
for example, is what you
should be fueling basically
before the race.
I will add in a little bit
of extra carbs the week
of the race.
But I don't go hog wild.
I don't go and sit
and have a giant bowl
of pasta the nice before.
I think I would spend half
my race in a Porta-John.
No joke.
Everything in moderation.
Anything extreme is
not what we're about.
Everything is all
about moderation.
So we find that it is important
to do the carbo loading,
but it's very small.
So more my snacks throughout
the week will be carbo-oriented.
But otherwise, I
eat exactly the way
I would eat through my training.
AUDIENCE: But do I need to limit
carb intake to lose weight?
SHALANE FLANAGAN: No.
ELYSE KOPECKY: Processed carbs.
There's a big difference
between processed carbs
and whole-food carbs.
So you do want to avoid
the processed carbs,
like the white flour and
white sugar and breads.
And all the packaged
foods out there
are made with really
highly processed carbs
that have no nutrients.
But the carbohydrates
we use in our books
are complex carbs, like sweet
potatoes, and whole grains,
and all these things
that are going
to be balanced energy versus
these unhealthy spikes that
not only cause you
to not feel great,
but will also lead
to weight gain
if you're eating
a lot of bad fat.
So it is good to avoid
the processed carbs.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just for a little bit
more on that specific question
again on carbs.
So you as an endurance
athlete, so you consume carbs.
But wheat, not white carbs?
So pasta, but like wheat pasta?
ELYSE KOPECKY: Yes.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Not white
rice, but brown rice?
SHALANE FLANAGAN: My favorite
carbohydrate is a sweet potato.
So the night before I
run the Boston marathon,
I'm loading up on
the sweet potato.
And Elyse can explain why.
A sweet potato is a great
source of a carbohydrate,
as opposed to we were talking
about the stripped flours that
really provide no nutrition.
ELYSE KOPECKY: Wheat pasta is
kind of misleading packaging.
Same with wheat bread.
If it says whole wheat
pasta or whole wheat bread
on the outside of the package.
If you flip to the back and
look at the actual ingredients,
if the first ingredient
is just wheat flour,
it's not actually whole wheat.
So when you're buying bread,
you want the first ingredient
to be whole wheat flour,
not just wheat flour.
And there's a lot of
other things like that
with misleading packaging.
We eat pasta.
We're not gluten-free,
but we don't
eat like a big mound of pasta.
Instead, we will have a
small serving of pasta
with a lot of sauce.
The sauce is packed
with veggies and meat
and all the good stuff.
And then, other good
carbohydrates for runners
is brown rice.
Or Shalane's favorite
is wild rice.
And we have a wild rice
salad in here that's amazing.
Or, farro or quinoa.
There's lots of
other great sources.
But we're not going
to say don't eat pasta
because we love pasta, too.
AUDIENCE: What about dairy?
Again, some authors
say don't consume
dairy-- yogurt, milk, cheeses.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Dairy?
AUDIENCE: Dairy, yes.
Sorry.
ELYSE KOPECKY: Yeah.
So dairy is pretty
hard to digest.
A lot of runners are
sensitive to dairy
and sensitive to gluten.
A lot of runners
suffer from GI distress
because when you're
running, your blood
is flowing away from
your digestive system
and going to your
hard-working muscles.
So dairy can be very hard
to digest because of how
it's processed in our country.
It's homogenized and
ultra-pasteurized.
So they're heating it to
these extreme temperatures.
So it's killing off all the
good probiotics and enzymes,
which makes it really
difficult to break down
the lactose in the dairy.
In our book, we don't
use cream or milk.
Instead, we use dairies
that are easier to digest,
like whole-milk yogurt,
which have probiotics in it.
And aged cheeses, like Parmesan.
When they age the cheese,
it has the enzymes
and is a lot easier to digest.
We also love goat cheese.
It doesn't have
the lactose that's
in dairy that a lot of
people have problems with.
AUDIENCE: Shalane, you don't
drink coffee with milk?
SHALANE FLANAGAN:
Coffee with milk?
AUDIENCE: No?
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Oh, no, I do.
But not a lot.
I prefer actually almond
milk most of the time.
I love my coffee.
ELYSE KOPECKY: Loves coffee.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
You mentioned that you used
to count your calories a lot.
And like, you wouldn't be
satisfied with the food
or happy with the food.
And once you changed to
this diet-- not diet.
I mean, way of eating,
it helped a lot
and you don't change
your diet much.
Can you elaborate
more on how much
you change your eating
close to a race,
or if you change at all?
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
So Elyse helped me realize
that the way our culture
and how we grew up, it was
ingrained to have everything
low-fat.
In my fridge, there
would be low-fat yogurt.
And I would have
fake butter spreads.
Thinking this was all
healthy, mind you.
I was thinking I was doing a
good job taking care of myself.
But it always left me hungry
and not feeling satiated.
I always felt like I was
constantly hungry and just
could never feel full.
And there was a reason why.
It's because I was eating
everything so low-fat.
And a lot of low-fat foods
just pump in a lot of sugar.
So my body was just burning it
and just ripping through it.
And so I was feeling hungry
all the time, which it's not
fun to run around hungry.
And I have a lot of training.
I run close to--
sometimes, 20 miles a day.
And that left me just
not in a good place.
So I felt like with
counting calories,
and having to eat all
these bland, boring foods,
I was just felt unmotivated,
and uninspired to eat,
and uninspired to get
in the kitchen and cook.
And once Elyse taught
me how to integrate,
like making my own salad
dressings with some really good
oils, eating chicken
thighs instead
of all the white breasts.
Having nice, buttery
sauces on my pasta.
I just started to feel
like it was more indulgent.
I was enjoying my food more.
And I just felt
like I didn't need
to count calories because
my weight was naturally
finding a good place.
And I didn't feel like I had
to stress about it anymore.
And she told me that.
She's like, the only numbers
you should be concerned about
are what your watch is reading.
And what your splits
are for your workouts.
How many miles
you're running a day.
Worry about those numbers.
Abandon the idea of
counting calories.
And plus, on top of that,
I couldn't count calories
because all the foods I was
eating were natural foods.
I don't know how many calories
are in each-- in an apple,
necessarily.
Every apple is different.
And when you're
eating whole foods,
there's no need to read
the nutrition label.
So it just completely opened
up my way of looking at food.
And it's been a huge relief.
And I have found that
here I am at age 35,
and I feel rejuvenated.
And I made my
fourth Olympic team.
And that's hard to do at my age.
There's not many
35-year-old Olympians.
And I feel like it's because
I've changed my diet.
Well, I shouldn't say "diet."
My way of eating now.
AUDIENCE: I have a
follow-up to that.
So sometimes, when
I'm heavy training,
I wake up hungry, like in
the middle of the night,
like 4:00 or 3:00.
Do you have this kind of stuff?
Or, do you change
your diet [INAUDIBLE]?
SHALANE FLANAGAN:
Yeah, I used to.
I used to always have
a snack by my bed.
Because I would wake up,
and I'd be like, oh my gosh.
I'm so hungry.
I can't wait till breakfast.
I have to grab a
snack right now.
So I used to literally
have food on my nightstand.
It was usually like a
packaged bar, or something.
Athletes, bars are always
pushed at you all the time.
So now, I go to bed and I'm
full throughout the night.
And I'm ready to
eat in the morning,
but I'm not in the
middle of the night.
The hunger pains
aren't waking me up,
which would happen a lot
when I'm training hard.
AUDIENCE: Before
I ask my question,
can I invite you ladies to sit?
You've been standing
while the rest of us
have been-- so I
was kind of curious
because there's a lot
of trends out there.
And one particular one-- I have
a friend who really got excited
at Soylent.
What is your take on Soylent?
ELYSE KOPECKY: Soy?
AUDIENCE: Soylent.
It's-- never mind.
The idea is that they're
sourcing a bunch of sugars
and fats from different
places, and then they put them
in a bottle or a powder.
So it's supposed to be
pre-balanced, all that stuff.
ELYSE KOPECKY:
That's frightening.
There's more to eating
than just the nutrients.
There's the act of eating
and sitting down to a meal,
being part of the community
and the social aspect
of eating food.
Cooking wakes up your
digestive system.
There's so much more to
eating than just drinking down
nutrients.
So those products scare me.
They're also really highly
processed in the lab
and it's not real food.
So again, not crazy
about that idea.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: I
never even heard of it.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a non-food question?
Like just a couple of
questions to Shalane
about running mostly?
My first question
was, can you comment,
like what is your opinion on
the recent amazing world record
by [INAUDIBLE] for the 10K?
Like what's your opinion there?
SHALANE FLANAGAN:
It's mind-blowing.
I can't even actually
even conceptualize.
So he's asking about
in the Olympics,
in the 10,000
meter, which I have
a bronze medal from Beijing,
China, in the 10,000 meters.
But in Rio this summer, there
was a woman from Ethiopia
who ran the world
record in the race.
And I couldn't believe
my eyes watching her.
It's beyond my comprehension.
AUDIENCE: And Shalane has
an American record for 10K.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
So she ran half of race faster
than I could run-- so at 5K,
or 5,000 meters, she's ran her
first 5,000 or her second 5,000
faster than I've run one.
So I can't even conceptualize.
It was just an
outstanding performance.
Unfortunately with
athletics, sometimes
what seems unbelievable
is unbelievable.
I don't know what to
think about it just
because, as maybe many of
you read over the summer,
there was a lot
of doping stories.
And with Russia being
extracted from the Olympics
and not allowed.
So it's just hard to know
what is real or not real.
However, I will say there's
not many 10,000-meter races
and opportunities
to run really fast.
So maybe she really
just is that good.
But we'll find out.
It was so impressive, yes.
AUDIENCE: And can you
just talk a little bit,
what is next for you?
More marathons--
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Athletically?
AUDIENCE: Running-wise, yes.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Well, I'm
taking a nice, little break
on this book tour.
It's fun to do
something different.
My lifestyle is
very monastic when
I'm training for a marathon.
It's three months of
a lot of dedication.
It's run, eat, sleep.
Run, eat, sleep, repeat.
It's very much the same thing.
It's what I call Groundhog Day.
If any of you have
seen that movie,
that's my life when I'm
training for a marathon.
It's not very eventful.
So it's fun for me to do other
activities, engage with people.
I feel like when I come out of
marathon training, I'm in shock
and I don't know how
to even communicate.
It's like, do I
even know English?
It's a little scary.
So it's fun to just be inspired
by my running community
and the cooking world.
And it motivates me to
get back to my training
by taking a break.
So probably come
December and January,
I'll be back at the
grind of run, eat, sleep.
And I have aspirations.
My love affair with
running is in Boston.
I love the Boston Marathon.
I grew up there.
So I may show up in
Boston next April.
That may be part of my plan.
But beyond that, I don't know.
I'm taking one race at a time.
A lot of athletes think
in four-year chunks.
But right now, I'm just
going to go month by month.
AUDIENCE: So I want to
ask about morning runs.
And you may have the luxury
not to have to deal with this.
But how do you deal when
you're trying to get
a long run in in the morning?
Do you wake up at 4:00 AM
to eat, and then go back
to sleep for a few hours?
SHALANE FLANAGAN: If
I'm just doing training,
like long-run training run?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
So I like to eat
about 90 minutes prior
to the start of a run.
And I know that that may be--
it's like a luxury for me,
because that's my job.
For example, if you were
wanting to start your run,
what, at like 5:00
AM, you're saying?
And you wanted to get
it in before work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Or, have family or
other commitments.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
You're trying to
get it done early.
AUDIENCE: You want to do like
three hours at 7:00 AM, 6:00
AM.
SHALANE FLANAGAN: Yeah.
I mean, the key in the morning--
and this is maybe a little
bit too much information--
is to get up and get
moving so that you're not
going to have any GI issues out
on the trail and having
to make a pit stop.
So that's usually what
most runners are like,
let's get up an hour before
to try and get some food in.
Make sure that you've
made your bathroom stop
and you can head out on
the trail, on the road,
and be good to go.
So I usually get up
about an hour before.
But sometimes, that's hard
to do if it's dark and cold.
But usually, on the ride
to-- if I'm going to go run,
to drive-- or drive
to go run, I will
take a smoothie or one
of our superhero muffins
and eat that right
before I get out there.
Yeah.
ELYSE KOPECKY: If you don't
have time for breakfast--
I run early before my
husband leaves for work
and before I start working.
So at that hour, at
6:00 AM, I'm not hungry.
So I'll just get up and
have some coconut water
mixed with water, like
diluted with water.
And either coffee or
tea and a couple of
dates just for
some quick energy.
But a three-hour
run is different.
I usually run less than that.
So you definitely want
to get some fuel in you.
And dates can be a
good, quick glucose hit.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
That's end of our talk.
We're going to have
a book signing over
at that table over there.
There's still some books
available for purchase
over here.
And everybody,
please give a warm
thank you to Shalan and Elyse.
[APPLAUSE]